black is pure premium hydration black is
premium you hurting your first premium
alkaline water it's pure it has 70 plus
trace minerals nan Jim oh maybe it's
like from the roots of a tree maybe it's
like dirt liquefied tastes kind of like
tasteless tea my mind wants to make me
think the head I'm drinking like
something that's not water but it tastes
just like water with a powerful
combination of electrolytes vital trace
minerals and an alkaline pH of eight
bill is pure premium hydration I don't
know what any of that stuff means it's
just water it's just plain water
I like this this black wire tastes just
like regular who would've thought I'm
gonna try and see if I know the
difference between regular water and
watch water oh my gosh I can't tell the
difference this one felt more like
authentic so I'm gonna say the one on my
left is water and the one on my right is
black on it this is a prank is it just
both regular water connect water oh so I
was right the minerals that are in here
are found in plants and soil and they're
highly nutritious Wow a call smart I am
I was like is probably dirt water but
healthy doesn't taste like refreshing is
water very tastes almost exactly the
same at the end of the day it tastes
like water it doesn't look like water
what's water
[Music]